you think about role-playing games you
become friends with certain characters
in that game they're they don't remember
much about you they they
they're they're just telling a story
it's exactly what you're saying they
they exist in that virtual world but if
they acknowledge that you exist in this
physical world if the characters in the
game remember that you exist that you
like for me like lex they understand
that i'm a human being who has like
hopes and dreams and so on it seems like
there's going to be a like
billions if not trillions of cosmos in
the world so if we look at that future
there's several questions to ask how
intelligent does that future cosmo need
to be
to create
fulfilling
relationships like friendships yeah it's
a great question and and part of it is
the recognition that's going to take
time to get there because it has to be a
lot more intelligent
because what's good enough to
be a magical experience for
uh you know an eight-year-old
it's a higher bar to do that be a
complaint like a pet in the home or to
help with functional interface in an
office environment or in a home or uh
and so forth and so and the idea was
that you build on that and you kind of
get there and as technology becomes more
prevalent and less expensive and so
forth you can start to kind of work up
to it um but you know you're absolutely
right at the end of the day um we almost
equated it to how uh the touchscreen
created like this really novel interface
to you know physical kind of devices
like this
this is the extension of it where you
have much richer physical interaction in
the real world this is this is the
enabler for it um and it shows itself in
a few kind of really obvious places so
just take something as simple as a voice
assistant um you will never most people
will never tolerate uh an alexa or a
google home just starting a conversation
um proactively uh when you weren't kind
of expecting it because it it feels
weird it's like you were listening and
like and then now you're kind of it
feels intrusive but if you had a
character um like a cat that touches you
and gets your attention or toddler like
you never think twice about it what we
found really kind of immediately is that
um these types of characters like cosmo
and they would like roam around and kind
of get your attention and we had a
future version that was always on um
kind of called vector people were way
more forgiving um and so you could
initiate interaction in a way that is
not acceptable for
for machines and in general um you know
there's a lot of ways to customize it
but it makes people who are skeptical of
technology much more comfortable with it
there was like there were a couple of
really really
prominent examples of this so when we
launched in europe and so we were in um
uh i think like a dozen countries if i
remember correctly but like we were we
went pretty aggressively
in launching in um germany and france
and uh in uk and we were very worried in
europe because there's obviously like a
really a socially higher bar for privacy
and you know security where you you've
heard about how many companies have had
troubles on uh uh that might things that
might have been okay in the us but like
are just not okay in germany and france
in particular um and so we were worried
about this because you have um you know
cosmo who's um uh you know in a future
product veteran like where you have
cameras you have microphones it's kind
of connected and like you're playing
with kids and like in these experiences
and you're like this is like ripe to be
like a nightmare if you're not careful
yes um and
uh and the journalists are like
notoriously like really really tough on
on these sort of things um
we were shocked and we prepared so much
for what we would have to encounter we
were shocked in that
not once from any journalists or
customer did we have any complaints
beyond like a really casual kind of
question
and it was because
of the character where um
when it conversation came up um it was
almost like well of course he has to see
in here how else is he going to be alive
and interacting with you um and it
completely disarmed um this like fear of
technology that enabled this interaction
to be much more fluid and again like
entertainment was a proving ground but
that is like a you know there's like
ingredients there that carry over to a
lot of other uh
elements down the road that's hilarious
that we're a lot less concerned about
privacy if the if the thing is value and
charisma
i mean that's true for all of coming to
human interaction too it's an
understanding of intent where like well
he's looking at me he can see me if he's
not looking at me he can't see me right
so it's almost like uh um you're
communicating intent and with that
intent
people are like kind of kind of more
understanding and calmer and it's a it's
interesting we just it was just the
earliest kind of version of starting an
experiment with this but um it wasn't
enabler and um and then and then you
have like completely different
dimensions where like you know kids with
autism had like an incredible connection
with cosmo that just went beyond
anything we'd ever seen and we have like
these just letters that we would receive
from parents and we had some research
projects kind of going on with some
universities on studying this but um
there are like there's an interesting
dimension there that got unlocked they
just hadn't existed before um that has
these really interesting kind of
links into society and uh and a
potential building block of future
experiences so
if you look out into the future do you
think we will have
beyond a particular game you know a
companion like uh like her
like the movie her or like a cosmo
that's
kind of asks you how your day went too
right
you know like a friend yeah do you how
how many years away from that do you
think we are what's your intuition good
question so
i think the idea of a different type of
character like more closer to like kind
of a pet style companionship will come
way faster um
and there's a few reasons one is like to
to do something like in her that's like
effectively almost general ai and the
bar is so high that if you miss it by
bit you hit the uncanny valley where it
just becomes creepy and like and not um
not appealing
because the closer you try to get to a
human in form and interface and
voice the harder it becomes whereas
you have way more flexibility on
still landing a really great experience
if you embrace the idea of a character
and that's why um
one of the other reasons why we didn't
have a voice uh and also why like a lot
of video game characters like
sims for example does not have a voice
when you uh when you think about it it
was it wasn't just a cost savings like
for them it was actually for all of
these purposes it was because when you
have a voice you immediately narrow down
the appeal to some particular
demographic or age range or
kind of style or gender
if you don't have a voice people
interpret what they want to interpret
and an eight-year-old might get a very
different interpretation than a 40 year
old
but you create a dynamic range and so
you just you can lean into these
advantages much more um and something
that doesn't resemble a human and so
that'll come faster
uh i don't know when a human like that's
just uh still like just complete r d at
this point the the chat interfaces are
getting way more interesting and richer
but it's still a long way to go to kind
of pass the test of
you know well let me like let's consider
like let me play devil's advocate
so google is a very large company that's
servicing
it's creating a very compelling product
that wants to provide a service a lot of
people but let's go outside of that
you said characters yeah it feels like
and you also said that it requires
general intelligence to be a successful
participant in a relationship which
could explain why i'm single this is
very but the i i honestly want to push
back on that a little bit because i feel
like is it possible
that if you're just good at playing a
character yeah
in a movie there's a bunch of characters
if you just understand what creates
compelling characters
and then you you just are that character
and you exist in the world and other
people find you and they connect with
you just like you do when you talk to
somebody at a bar i like this character
this character is kind of shady i don't
like them you pick the ones that you
like and you know maybe it's somebody
that's uh reminds you of your father or
mother i don't know what it is but the
the freudian thing but there's some kind
of connection that happens and that's
that that's the cosmo you connect to
that's the future cosmo you connect and
that's
so i guess the statement i'm trying to
make is it possible to achieve a depth
of friendship without solving general
intelligence i think so and it's about
intelligent kind of constraints right
and just uh you set expectations and
constraints such that in the space
that's left you can be successful and so
you can do that by having a very focused
domain that you can operate in for
example you're a customer support agent
for a particular product and you create
intelligence and a good interface around
that or
uh
you know kind of in the personal
companionship side you can't be
everything to
across the board
you you kind of solve those constraints
and i think uh i think it's possible my
my worry is like i
right now i don't see anybody that has
picked up on where kind of cosmo left
off yes and is pushing on it in the same
way and so i don't know if it's a sort
of thing where similar to like how you
know in dot com there were all these
concepts that we considered like you
know that didn't work out or like failed
or like were too early or whatnot and
then 20 years later you have these like
incredible successes on almost the same
concept like it might be that sort of
thing where like there's another pass at
it that happens in five years or in 10
years but um it does feel like that
appreciation of that like the this the
three-legged stool if you will between
like you know the hardware the ai and
the character um that balance it's hard
to
i'm not aware of of any pro anywhere
right now where like that same kind of
aggressive drive with the value on the
character is uh is happening and so to
me
just a prediction exactly as you said
something that looks awfully a lot like
cosmo not in the actual physical form
but in the three-legged stool
something like that in some number of
years will be a trillion dollar company
i don't understand like it's obvious to
me
that
like
character not just as robotic companions
but in all our computers they'll be
there it's like uh
clippy was like
two legs of that stool or something like
that yeah i mean that those are all
different attempts and
what's really confusing to me
is they
they're born
these attempts and they
everybody gets excited and for some
reason they die and then nobody else
tries to pick it up and then maybe a few
years later
a crazy guy like you comes comes around
with just enough brilliance and vision
to create this thing and it's born a lot
of people love it a lot of people get
excited but maybe the timing is not
right yet
and then and then
when the timing is right it just blows
up it just keeps blowing up more and
more until it just blows up and i guess
everything in the full span of human
civilization collapses eventually
and that wouldn't surprise me at all and
like what's going to be different in
another five years or ten years what not
physical component costs will continue
to come down uh in price and you know
mobile devices and computations going to
become more more prevalent as well as
cloud as a big tool to offload cost um
ai is going to be a massive
transformation compared to what we dealt
with
where
everything from voice understanding to
um uh to just
you know kind of a broader contextual uh
understanding and mapping of
of
semantics and uh understanding scenes
and so forth and then the character side
will continue to kind of you know
progress as well because that magic does
exist it just exists in different forms
um and you have just the brilliance of
uh uh that's happening in animation and
you know these other areas where um that
is that was a big unlock in um you know
in film obviously
and so i think yeah the pieces can
reconnect and the building blocks are
actually going to be way more impressive
than they were five years ago so
you